Tại vì đình tại hiện đệ 5 mi chính và lột thực hiện rất trụ ở cơ sở
từ năm 2020, việc bãi nhận trường thôn
tổ chừng tổ dân phố bắt bộ phải đực thông qua ý kiến của cộng đồng dân cơ
Trường thôn, tổ chừng dân phố có thể xin thuộc việc nếu có lý dò chính đáng và người đơn đến 8 nhân dân cấp sát
trong các trường hợp khác như không hoàn thành nhiệm vụ, vì phạm pháp lột tham nhúng không còn tính nghiệp
thì trường bãi công tác mặt trận có thể đy nghĩ bãi nhận nếu được ít nát 5 mi phần chăm số hộ dân trong khu vực đồng thận
việc chào thôi chức chỉ được thực hiện xó khi tổ chức hợp cộng đồng dân cơ theo đúng quy trình
dưới thiệu người thay thế, nếu có thảo lợp, điều quyết bằng dư tay hợp bỏ phía kính
kết quả điều quyết phải được lập thành bên bản và người ui bán nhân dân xát, ui bán mặt trận tổ quốc Việt Nam cấp xá trong bòng năm này
Đây là bước tiến quan trọng trong thực hiện dân chú ở cơ sở, bảo đam quyền giám sát và quyết định của mình dân với cánh bộ cơ sở
Đồng thời gian với UCO Sắp, tinh gọi bộ máy theo điện án tổ chức lại đứng bị hành chính xe đoạn 2, 2, 2, 1, 1, 1, 1, 1